chaque oeil maintenant juliette et
guillaume depardieu
mardi comment ça va
selon saint marc guillaume est rentré le
soir les terrans très directement je
suis retrouvé dans une galère tous les
deux ah bon à 4h du mat la wii un moment
celle il faut s'arracher
toi tu es rentrée c'est bien sagement
sagement finalement tué c'était rue de
ponthieu je n'en dirai pas plus no
coment bonsoir ça va on sort série oui
ça va bien alors guillaume avant de
parler de l'album de juliette qui est
excellent journée quand même que tu
réagisses au témoignage de cynthia
difficile d'avoir des parents célèbres
apparemment non luc ferry n'est pas très
philosophe les victoires tu as trouvé
qu'il est encore d'oignons je suis tu
penses que il a manqué de compassion
dans sa dans ses réactions aux livres de
nom il était assis populo quoi qu'est ce
que tu aurais à lui dire toi par rapport
à ce que j'ai dit luc ferry avance ce
qu'elle fait alors gilles et c'est
l'explosion annonce ayela oui ressemble
un peu tous là pour l'instant c'est
énorme là ce qui se passe en ce moment
non c'est marrant c'est un développement
de carrière il ya deux écoles
développement de carrière en un an deux
ans et moi ça prend 20 ans mais je vois
là d'un coup ça marche
il ya des articles dans tous les
journaux on vous voit dans beaucoup
d'émissions
il ya de la pub télé en plus on peut pas
regarder la télévision sans voir un
petit spot pour votre nouvel album aussi
agaçant que les choristes que amélie
poulain en son temps et tous à dire
comment tu connais pas juliette ont
nourri chat passe à sa mère
en tous les cas l'album est très bien
accueilli c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire ça s'appelle mutatis mutandis c'est
la première grosse surprise de l'année
2005 en tous les cas une des unes des
meilleures ventes depuis l'album d'ariel
qui continue à bien se vendre derrière
un choix
lumine par jour quand je lis une presse
très très élogieuses oui depuis des
années la presse était logique oui oui
mais là est d'autant plus élogieuses
qu'elle est relayée par un par la télé
par la radio il ya un premier single qui
passent beaucoup en radio ouais c'est la
première fois que ça peut les garçons de
mon quartier
pourtant vivement
son défi
et
à mi journée mais mon bus comme
ce
m
juliette maintenant maintenant ça marche
très bien pour nous vous est ce que vous
avez fait la connaissance d'orlando pas
tout de suite non non pas encore je vais
être approché j'espère j'espère bien
mais ce n'est que orlando exige le clip
oui tout le temps tout le temps dont
vous allez regarder votre caméra celle
où yann rougier vous avez dire magnéto
serge magnéto serge